el costo de vida es un fenómeno global
en américa latina' se traduce en falta
de poder adquisitivo para comprar los
alimentos básicos
en marzo la inflación interanual de
argentina registró una subida del 55 1%
28 puntos porcentuales por encima de la
variación registrada en febrero ya voy
al mercado y sólo traigo yogurt y ferial
y no puedo traer el fideo y el arroz
no me alcanza ni para la carne ya vamos
a un comedor cocinamos nos dan comidas
pero ahora me al comedor les llega
alimentos así que venimos a pedir un
poco de alimento para los chicos en perú
cindy cueto y su familia se preguntan a
diario qué vamos a comer allí en lima
esta mujer de 39 años y sus vecinos se
han unido para realizar lo que llaman
una olla común para hacerle frente a la
inflación que golpea principalmente al
30 por ciento de la población que según
cifras oficiales vive con tan sólo 3
dólares al día en ese país no carne de
res no pero siempre compramos huesos va
a ser sopa
anja sopa para hacer con más y menestrón
paisa si compramos verduras y la sopa
que siempre hacemos a la semana una vez
hacemos la sopa de hueso
el mercado de pescado y mariscos más
grande del continente tampoco se salvó
de los estragos de la inflación en
méxico la tasa de inflación interanual
en marzo subió hasta el 7 45% su mayor
nivel desde 2001 en chile- el índice de
precios al consumidor aumentó en marzo
un 9,4 por ciento comparado con marzo de
2021 muy por encima de la meta de entre
el 2 y el 4 por ciento que preveía el
banco central chileno los bancos
centrales de colombia y brasil también
viven la presión de incrementar los
tipos de interés para contener la subida
de precios
[Música]